[Musique]
on va gagner cette bataille comté par
comté région par région
tous enfants les québécoises et les
québécois veut exige du changement cette
année à la can on est là pour faire plus
pour faire mieux pour tous les québécois
ont fait parce qu'on pense que ce qu'on
pense c'est ce qu'elle québec mérite
manon massé bonjour bonjour avec les
autres chefs nous faisons une première
partie en marchant elle c'est encore
difficile pour vous commencez votre
globalement de mieux en mieux je me
déplace assez bien partir du moment le
fauteuil roulant derrière nous une somme
que tout vaut mieux laisser les tables
équipe i à quel moment vous pensez
pouvoir marcher comme avant ben
définitivement pour la campagne
électorale mais
je vous savez le physio c'est pas un art
de prédiction c'est très long c'est
difficile alors mais je pense bien que
d'ici à deux semaines
ça sera peut-être le passage à la can
puis après ça sur nos deux jambes parce
que ça doit vous angoissez quand même
entre quoi vous énervez parce qu on
entre on est à 100 jours de l'élection
veriez mais évidemment ça n'arrive pas
être en pleine possession de vos moyens
fusée c'est physique une campagne
électorale c'est très physique c'est
très épuisant oui mais en même temps moi
je veux tourner le bon côté des choses
dans vie en même temps ça m'a forcé à
m'arrêter
ça me forcer à réfléchir avoir le temps
parce que vous savez dans le tourbillon
dans le tourbillon du parlementarisme
dans le tourbillon de la préparation
électorale du travail de conté il ya un
gros tourbillon mais là quand vous avez
trois heures de physio par jour ben vous
avez juste le temps de vous arrêter
réfléchir et surtout vous assurer de
guérir complètement
pour être en forme pleinement à partir
du mode aux 7 et récent ce que vous
dites ça m'a permis de m'arrêter
est ce que vous avez pu voir qu'on sort
de la bulle de québec du parlement les
travers un peu de ce monde là où on
n'arrête pas de s'engueuler le jour
période des questions le soir il ya des
amitiés qui se lit est-ce quelque chose
de deux mâles 5 selon vous dans cette
joute politique c'est clair que c'est
une bulle
c'est une bulle tout le monde vivent
dans ce but là c'était frappant de voir
le décalage lorsque j'étais en centre de
réadaptation j'avais le temps ge avec
les gens ce que les gens me parlaient ce
que je veux suivait dans l'actualité
politique du parlement c'est ses
demandes
les gens ne sont pas là les gens sont
préoccupés de ce qui leur arrive a eu
des impacts bien sûr des choix
politiques ont fait les liens mais
écoutez là ce qui se passe à l'assemblée
nationale ça demeure une bulle
vous avez vraiment envie de faire de la
politique de sauter sur la glace comme
vous le dites parce que ça vous a pris
les gens oublient ça peut-être ça vous
aux prises cinq
fois vous oui c'est me suis présenté à
cinq reprises
et quand vous dites que les campagnes
électorales c'est physique
alors juste à votre j'ai fait 2006 2007
2008 2012 et finalement 2014 donc cinq
élections en moins de 8 ans et je
travaille à temps plein parce que
fallait je gagne mon pain fait oui ça
m'a pris cinq fois mais ce qui était
très positif c'est qu'à chaque fois on
augmentait le nombre de personnes qui se
reconnaissent dans québec solidaire qui
disaient oui à manon massé jusqu'à temps
que quatre 2014 c'est arrivé pour vrai
et depuis 2014
vous ne regrettez jamais d'être entré en
politique active au parlement québec
c'est utile ça fait une différence
ben c'est classe québec québec solidaire
était pas au parlement
je pense que la différence ne
s'exprimerait pas parce que vous savez
les préoccupations de changement que les
gens me parlent beaucoup sur le terrain
de ces deux ça que les gens pas sont
année ils veulent que ça change
ben pour changer faut faire différent
les trois autres partis ont pas cette
tendance cofaq pour moi ce que
j'aspirais de provoquer le changement
ben oui ça me le permet on va faire une
pause mais juste avant votre état
d'esprit le cas avant d'entrer sur le
ring parce que ça reste une bataille
cette affaire vous avez des peurs des
craintes comment vous sentez lol à 100
jours ben en fait je suis plutôt très
enthousiaste parce que une campagne
électorale c'est ce que j'ai fait depuis
35 ans ce à dire aller vers les gens
parler avec les gens déconstruire les
maîtres les préjugés les discours
dominants
c'est mon travail des 35 dernières
années en moi j'adore les campagnes
électorales en terme de parts ben
j'espère que mes deux jambes seront
aller aussi vite que moi
animation fait une courte pause au
retour on va parler de votre programme
de certains aspects de votre programme
qui déjà font jaser comme les soins
dentaires on vient à tout de suite dans
vous répondez quoi au doyen de
l'assemblée nationale qui vous accusent
être la gauche caviar maintenant à cette
loi
[Musique]
québec soldats c'est le parti des
québécois et québécoises solidaire manon
massé l'éducation sera peut-être puis on
se croise les doigts que ça le soit un
thème important lors de cette campagne
électorale parce que souvent on veut que
ce soit un thème important qu'on parle
souvent d'autre chose vous il ya un
point dans votre programme
gros programme vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup de choses on est une vision
complète un projet mais pour l'éducation
vous dites il faut mettre la hache dans
les écoles privées fini au revoir en
fait on dit pas qu'il faut mettre la
hache dans les écoles privées ce qu'on
dit ces cétacés le financement ciblé on
leur donne plus aux choux mais voilà on
cesse le financement public des écoles
privées
pourquoi ben simplement pour achever le
projet initial de rendre notre école
publique partout sur le territoire
pareil est ce qu'on se rend compte ce
qui a une majorité en fait puisque c'est
de l'argent public
l'ensemble des québécois et québécoises
contribuer à financer l'école privée
alors que pierre hugues gens qui n'y ont
pas accès il ya des gens qui disent on
peut pop physique
on ne peut pas intégrer tous les écoles
du réseau privé au réseau public ça se
fait pas est ce un autre exemple de
mesures irréaliste que vous proposez ben
écoutez nous on les écoles privées qui
veulent rester des écoles privées sans
fonds publics et continueront n'y a pas
de problème nous on pense que à peu près
la moitié des élèves qui vont migrer
vers le public parce que la moitié des
écoles vont choisir d'aller plutôt dans
le système public et à ce moment là vous
dites est réaliste moi j'embarque dans
cette affaire là on arriverait enfin à
peu près 6 % d'élèves dans le privé
comme c'est à peu près la moyenne
canadienne actuellement alors c'est très
réaliste note à faire et on ne fera pas
en un coup on se donne un mandat de
quatre ans pour y arriver il y en a qui
vous a piqué et quelques jours le doyen
de l'assemblée nationale avant de partir
enfin une entrevue
françois gendron en dix ans québec
solidaire c'est la gauche caviar ils
disent qu'ils veulent dans le programme
mais il ya ce n'est pas assez enraciné
puis par réalise vous répondez quoi au
doyen de l'assemblée nationale qui vous
accuse d'être la gauche caviar marois
c'est waouh
bah écoutez moi quand j'ai vu le dernier
sondage léger et que j'ai vu que les
quatre premières mesures souhaitées par
la population du québec c'est des
mesures portées par québec solidaire
c'est nous on est décroché je sais pas
de quoi on parle je parle justement la
question de l'urgence sûr que monsieur
legault vous dit que 90 minutes
d'ailleurs jean oui mais comment comment
il va faire ça nous c'est clair celle-ci
27 capes
on dit depuis douze ans et c'est la
porte d'entrée ce n'est plus des
urgences dans un québec solidaire en
quatre sets 24 7j dînette
c'est quand même je sers drouet weiwei
talent vous êtes encore pire est passé
le clc 24,7 donc porte d'entrée pour
l'ensemble des québécois et québécoises
sur l'ensemble du territoire
deuxième mesure assurance dans ta pour
tout le monde ça s'écrit mec soldats
point barre là c'est pas décroché 76% du
peuple québécois veulent une assurance
dentaire pour tout le monde
troisième mesure la question du
transport collectif
il faut rendre accessible québec
solidaire diminué de 50% alors comprenez
vous moins que comme dit qu'on est pas
réaliste
moi je pense que c est eux qui sont à
côté de la track parce que dans les
faits les gens nous démontre que on
aiderait dans le monde en tout cas vous
mettez des questions sur la place
publique pour qu'on en dise que oui
j'aime pas mais est ce que vraiment ne
le financement prenons lille soins
dentaires s'intéresse à beaucoup de gens
qui ont accroché on dit il ya des gens
qui malheureusement ne peuvent pas se
payer des dentistes est-ce que c'est
réaliste de dire oui on peut y aller on
peut se payer ce qu'elle est ou serait
ce une question de choix politique à
québec salle d'arts on a le courage
d'aller chercher de l'argent ce qui je
vous donne un exemple pour que tout le
monde le sache cette mesure là pour
permettre à tous les québécois et toutes
les québécoises d'avoir accès à une
assurance dentaire
ça coûte environ 950 millions
ben nous ou ce qu'on va les prendre sur
950 millions là on va dire aux médecins
aux médecins spécialistes c'est too much
on rouvre l'entente on s'assure que vous
soyez bien sûr à égalité avec l'ontario
est ce ça va rapporter comment combien
950 millions donc moralité choix des
sommes que les médecins ont négocié elle
vous rouvrez l'entente qu'a revenir en
arrière
absolument on le dit depuis le déclin il
ya plusieurs médecins qui sont en accord
avec ça et ceux qui nous disent que ça
se fait pas notamment monsieur bart être
le parti libéral ben ils oublient que
mme heim ont réouvert l'entente des
retraités municipaux puis ont eu aucun
scrupule à le faire alors oui ça se fait
immigration
est ce que vous dites les portes sont
ouvertes venait il y en a pas de limite
monsieur legault veut abaisser aux
pertes parti québécois ou si on veut
abaisser
on dit que ça va leur politique vont
abaisser le nombre de nouveaux arrivants
par année vous vous dites on ouvre les
portes pas de limites en tête
actuellement les cibles sont là pour
nous nous apparaissent réalise la
différence en québec soldats c'est ce
que je faisais part faire différent pour
nous loin notre mesure concrète c'est
d'assurer des emplois aux gens qui
viennent qui nous choisissent comme pays
comme lieu de résidence et pour nous
l'immigration c'est pas un problème
c'est pas quelque chose qu'il faut
régler parce que ça fait pas c'est au
contraire du monde qui nous choisissent
pour venir nous aider à réaliser notre
projet de société moi je trouve ça
extraordinaire mais le seuil actuel vous
semble correct voulait pas augmenter le
seuil actuel nous sommes correctes
maintenant ce qu'il faut c'est les
intégrer et nous ce qu'on propose comme
mesure on a dû souvent comme
gouvernement sur la fonction publique et
nous on propose d'embaucher à la hauteur
du nombre qui représente dans notre
société autour de 18% d'embaucher des
gens des communautés culturelles et des
minorités visibles sur la question de
l'identité c'est là vraiment qui eut un
schisme en tout cas une fracture avec le
parti québécois est énorme avec
l'histoire de la chappe à l'époque
est-ce que ça
c'est pas ce qui affecte dans votre
esprit vous êtes dit où le pq pour un
bond ou sait jamais je ne veux pas parce
que vous avez milité contre le
rapprochement avec le pécule
c'est à dire j'ai voté contre et c'est
clair que la perspective
d'interculturalisme que porte
québec solidaire de laïcité cette
perspective d'une ligne très claire
entre l'état et les individus c'est pas
la même jour on parle pas de la même
chose nous quand on parle de laïcité on
parle de laïcité de l'état
yo je dirais des chemins qui sont assez
irréconciliables mais ça c'est pas c'est
pas un regard de l'immigration c'est un
regard de l'intégration et pour nous à
québec solidaire
c'est fondamental compte que les gens
qui nous ont choisis ben on partage avec
les autres on est en manque d'employés
on est en manque de force de travail
pourquoi ça pose un problème que ses
ingénieurs agronomes médecins
infirmières qui viennent de partout à
travers le monde puisse se mettre au
service de l'ensemble du peuple
québécois - n'y a pas d'enjeu le sud
mais le consensus de dire pour les gens
notorité pas de signes religieux aux
gets d'accord c'est ce qui nous est
apparu comme étant le compromis pas sûr
que c'est un consensus qu'un compromis
qui malheureusement est déjà présent
dans l'espace public depuis au moins
deux ans d'année et à chaque minute
qu'on attende de plus c'est une minute
qu'on s'éloigne du compromis parce que
je vous donne cet exemple là parce que
on se pose la question des fois pourquoi
québec solidaire et si agressif avec le
parti québécois on a l'impression que le
pq et vous c'est presque pire d'entre
vous et libérons vous la 4k quelque
chose de alors que le pq ce s'est un peu
mis sur sa gauche depuis quelques mois
et serait peut être possible ya beaucoup
de gens qui vous tendait la main au
parti québécois
vous vous dites ça et c'est un moment
parce que nous on parle jamais du pq on
n'arrête pas de nous poser des questions
mais nous
la voix du vécu nous là on se prononce
clairement sur où elle se situe une
indifférence qui voit l'arrivée a fait
mal parti québécois bien actuellement
est ce que c'est vraiment nous la cac
qui fait mal au parti québécois
lâchez nous sommes nous là on est
différent des trois autres pains ou lors
des trois autres lorsqu'elles ces trois
parties la ont voté en faveur que l'
équilibre budgétaire comme disait le
parti libéral à l'époque se fasse en un
an
les trois ont voté pour ou se sont
abstenus
et nous on a voté contre c'est ce
qu'apporte québec soldats parce que le
déficit pour vous pas une religion aucun
déficit que l'état du québec puisse
faire un déficit c'est acceptable
ben oui ça allait pas pourquoi si c'est
pour financer le deal relier les trois
autres c'est devenu c'est on ne va pas
là du côté des devises
on ne va pas là mais ne pas aller là
dans notre corps ça veut dire d'aller
chercher de l'argent ailleurs pas de
couper d'un service vous savez monsieur
legault arrivé avec sa mesure
extraordinaire de baisser les impôts
waouh le plq vient de le faire le pécule
le fait avant y'a rien de changement là
dedans rien 9 et répètent l'histoire
ils font les mêmes affaires nous ce
qu'on dit c'est il faut investir bien
sûr des services publics
on l'a eue depuis des mois des années
mais pour le faire on va on va avoir le
courage d'aller chercher l'argent ce qui
est qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez le 1er
octobre comme résultat idéal avoir un
peu plus tôt parce que vous savez très
bien ne prendrait pas le pouvoir là
dedans qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez et
lyon la ligne du succès ou de l'échec
chez québec solidaire je vous dirais
deux choses premièrement je vous dirai
arrêtez de décider pour le peuple auquel
c'est le peuple qui va décider si on va
être là ou si on sera pas c'est le
peuple qui va décider si nos
propositions concrètes avec notre cadre
financier équilibré
d'ailleurs depuis qu'on se présente en
politique c'était qu'il brille saison
qui décideront alors moi c'est la
première nous fatiguer
avec vos noms mais j'ai réalisé qu'à
force de répéter et de dire que les
sondages finalement vont donner raison
nous donnons attendent et nous on fait
notre travail on est sur le terrain on
voit que nos idées résonne répondre aux
besoins du peuple québécois comme est
née en moi je vous pose la question qui
est légitime où est la ligne du succès
ou de l'échec le plus de députés
inévitablement c'est un succès parce que
c'est plus de force de travail on le
voit depuis caméra est élu un député
seulement à chaque fois c'est épuisant
les plus sains parce qu'on fait
exactement les mêmes choses que tous les
autres partis mais avec énormément moins
de moyens en omaha si vous restez avec
nous après la pose des questions en
rafale
d'accord
seriez-vous main dans la main avec
justin trudeau pour contrer la guerre
commerciale de monsieur choix
[Musique]
manon massé les questions en rafale
on commence où tu étais ce qu'il est
possible de permettre un temps
d'attentes maximum aux urgences et si
oui combien de temps ben en fait ce qui
est important c'est tout ce qui vient
avant qui va nous permettre d'arrêter de
prendre l'urgence comme une porte
d'entrée et pour nous c'est l'ouverture
des clsc 24 heures 7 jours semaine
ok mais pas de 90 minutes pour voir un
médecin
ben écoutez moi je pense quand tu vois
c'est laisser tu peux le voir très
rapidement
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
donner de l'argent public pour la
construction de nouveaux stades de
baseball à montréal
je pense que l'argent qui se fait
l'odieux argent qui se fait dans ce type
d'activité la nécessite pas d'argent
public pour nous est-ce que ça a été une
erreur de construire le centre vidéotron
à québec avec essentiellement de
l'argent public
c'était une très grave erreur et c'est
encore les citoyens qui payent pour soi
seriez-vous main dans la main avec
justin trudeau pour contrer la guerre
commerciale de monsieur tron ben
inévitablement il faut s'élever contre
la guerre commerciale mais se trompe
mais pour québec solidaire main dans la
main avec monsieur trudeau c'est pour
possible on est un parti indépendantiste
et c'est debout face à monsieur tram
qu'on va assumer cette guerre
commerciale
est ce que vous seriez prête à faire des
concessions pour la gestion de l'offre
ce que demande des américains je pense
que la gestion de l'offre est une façon
dont le québec s'est doté pour assurer
une répartition de l'argent sur
l'ensemble de nos producteurs et tu
verras il faut inévitablement mettre
notre pied à terre par rapport à ça
limiter à deux le nombre maximum de
mandats pour une ou un premier mineur au
québec vous d'accord ben moi
personnellement mon parti a pas de
position là dessus mais moi
personnellement je vous dirais que pour
l'ensemble des députés ça pourrait être
une bonne idée parité obligatoire en soi
conseil des ministres est très calme
malheureusement mon projet de loi a été
rejetée parce que je les dépose et
dernièrement
et pour moi c'est juste une question de
logique salaire minimum à 15 dollars ou
quatrième semaine de vacances bleues
travaillant pour moi les deux sont
conjugue à bhl d'un jeu en même temps
oui les deux effectivement et à québec
soldats on veut soutenir les pme pour
passer au travers ça est ce que le
gouvernement du québec un contrôle sur
le prix de l'essence qui ressemblent
souvent la collusion
je vous dirais que le prix de l'essence
c'est quelque chose qui frappe fort à
québec solidaire on s'en vient avec un
plant anciens énergétique qui va tout
aussi frappé fort ok mais pour contrôler
pour les consommateurs de ce conte un
contrôle sur ce que font les détaillants
je pense que les gouvernements très peu
de contrôles cdci d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous allez essayer un test de goût à la
sqc la nouvelle société du québec du
cannabis à l'une ferrandez debout quand
ça va être une bonne écoute et j'ai
aucun plaisir à fumer du cannabis
salorges très peu un test de goût mais
la saaq sans problème
est ce que le québec se porte mieux
aujourd'hui qu'il y a quatre je pense
que le québec à travers son plein emploi
aux apparences de se porter mieux mais
quand je regarde ce qui se passe dans
nos services publics
quand je regarde les argent qu'on
investit en quarts des énergies fossiles
moi je pense qu'il se porte pas mieux ok
mais vous vous reconnaissez quand même
qu'il ya eu des gains pour l'emploi
absolument mais en même temps quel type
d'emploi c'est des emplois
majoritairement où il ya majoritairement
masculin je pense qu'il faut avoir une
vision d'ensemble les services publics
ce job de femme personne n'a perdu
première priorité comme premier ministre
ben moi je vous dirais que à québec
soldats prendre soin du monde c'est
notre priorité
alors c'est de s'assurer qui a au niveau
de la santé au niveau de l'éducation par
exemple le projet
l'assurance dentaire pour tout le monde
ça fait partie de nos priorités
mais notre grande priorité c'est
d'enclencher le processus d'indépendance
du québec pour les électeurs pour les
québécois ce qui est un avantage avoir
un gouvernement minoritaire
moi je pense qu'un avantage d'avoir une
réforme du mode de scrutin et là dessus
j'espère que monsieur le gourmet se
lisait vont respecter leur parole et
pourquoi parce que justement ça crée des
gouvernements qui doivent collaborer et
moi je crois en la collaboration mais
est-ce qu'un avantage avons un
gouvernement minoritaire c'est de la
collaboration pour un certain temps mais
ce que ça nous prend surtout et nous on
va collaborer si besoin mais pour
s'assurer qu'il ya une réforme une
réforme du mode de scrutin terminant
manon massé quel est votre manière de
vous évader
est-ce que vous priez est ce que vous
faites du sport est ce que vous quel est
votre manière de vous évader
moi je suis une fille qui viennent la
campagne gn ou en dehors
alors pour moi est en nature être dans
le bois être sur l'eau dans l'eau ce
définitivement des façons de prendre
soin de moi un homme assez bonne chance
on se revoit le 13 septembre pour le
débat ça me fait plaisir les réformes et
de jambes
merci à bientôt à bientôt
[Musique]